y todo parece tranquilo en el camino
hacia la región del donbass de repente
un grupo de tanques aparece al lado de
la carretera quince de ellos son apenas
una pequeña representación de los
100.000 efectivos desplegados en el
oeste del país cerca de allí en el
pueblo están ve que es imposible no
notar el regreso de los soldados pero
quienes viven allí se han acostumbrado a
la posibilidad de que la guerra toque
sus puertas
los soldados están aquí en nuestro país
no nos hacen ningún daño desde 2014 esta
es una rusa está en la primera fila del
conflicto en la región del donbass
incluso algunos residentes de donde
buscan refugio del pueblo de flexión
votamos está aquí para ellos es más
fácil
y no estás rodeado de combates como allá
no hay un miedo constante a la muerte
allí el presidente ruso es visto como un
protector y la presencia del ejército es
tranquilizadora
que piensas que nuestras fronteras no
deben ser protegidas que debemos ser
abandonados bien hecho putting el nos
defiende
consideran que la amenaza proviene de
ucrania el discurso oficial ruso es que
su vecino está preparando provocaciones
contra los separatistas en la región del
donbass